SAURABH GUPTA:
Hello, and welcome
to Understanding Audience
Experiences on Google Cloud
Platform.
My name is Saurabh
Gupta, and I'm
a customer engineer
at Google Cloud
for Media and Entertainment.
Media streaming has
a global audience
with wide variances in
device types, user locations,
connection bandwidth,
and user behaviors.
Today, I'll be talking
about large-scale media
analytics for digital streaming
and how Google Cloud's products
can make it easy to ingest,
analyze, and get insights
at scale from millions of
users watching your content.
This demo shows the
power of Google Cloud's
fully-managed Enterprise
Data Warehouse, BigQuery,
along with Google Cloud's
fully-managed Enterprise Data
Visualization tool called Looker
to explore the media audience
experience and answer the
question how many people are
finishing their videos.
Over the past few days,
members of my team
have been watching
various short movies.
Events are emitted from
the Shaka player running
in the browser being used for
these movie watching sessions.
These events are
transmitted to an ingest end
point running on the Cloud
Run Serverless platform.
The events are
enqueued onto PubSub,
which is a fully-managed
global event streaming system.
Dataflow is a unified stream
and batch data processing
service based on Apache Beam.
Dataflow uses the events stream
from PubSub as a data source
and inserts the
data into BigQuery.
Looker is then used
to visualize the data
and get meaningful
insights from it.
So over to the demo.
Here, you can see a simulation
of a streaming services video
library, just as
what a streaming
customer might be expected to
see in their streaming service.
As a user, I can select
any movie to watch.
Before we begin, let us activate
the browser's debug window,
so we can see the
events that are
being emitted for analytics.
Let me now select one of my
favorite movies, "Caminandes."
The video starts playing
in the video page
and a sample Preroll ad
starts before the video.
You can see the different ad
quartile events being emitted.
Let me click on the ad, which
takes me to the ad's details
page, where a
customer would likely
see the details of the ad
they've just clicked on.
Let's return to the video
and continue playing.
As expected, other
events continue to fire.
Let me mute, and you can see
that event being emitted.
And let me pause the video.
And again, all these events
are streaming directly
into BigQuery.
So let's take a
look at BigQuery.
Here is where the events would
land in a specific data set.
I can run a sample query
to see these events land
in BigQuery in near real time.
This query shows
me all the events
that have accumulated
in the past 1 minute,
including the events
related to pausing the ad
and pausing the video as I
issued them on the player.
All of these events can
be analyzed in Looker
using visual dashboards.
Let's take a look at that.
Here is the Media Event
Analytics dashboard
that we've created in Looker
based on the data in BigQuery.
Up here, you can see the
total number of events
that we have logged,
the number of sessions
we've encountered
this month, and, most
importantly, the
viewership funnel,
which shows us the
progression of viewership
from one quartile of
the video to the next.
So we can see the number
of starts, mid-points,
and completion of videos.
We can also see where
customers are watching
the videos in a map view.
Additionally, we can also
see the device breakdown
and get session level details.
Further down, we can also
break down the ad funnel
in terms of how many
ads were started,
how many were completed, and
how many were clicked through.
We can also get details
on a particular asset
and drill into that.
So here, let's select
"Sintel" and see
the details of what this
specific asset is collecting
from an analytic standpoint.
Again, the data that we got at
the coarse-grained gross level,
we can now drill down
at a finer level and get
details about this
specific video
in terms of how many events
were issued against it,
how many sessions,
the viewership funnel,
the completion rates, devices,
ads, sessions, and also
geographic distribution.
Let us now return
to the presentation.
As you just saw,
BigQuery and Looker
provide a unified view
of data across ads,
players, and other sources of
data regarding your streaming
platform.
BigQuery and Looker
offer self-service access
to key insights for the
various stakeholders,
thus allowing better and
more timely decision making.
And since these are
fully-managed serverless
components, you're freed
from the overhead of managing
infrastructure and can focus
on running your business.
BigQuery and Looker make
a powerful combination
for streaming media analytics,
allowing you to unify analytics
across ads, content,
viewers, and other sources,
derive meaningful
insights in minimal time
leading to deep understanding
of the audience experience
for actionable outcomes.
Thanks for watching
Understanding the User
Experience on Google Cloud demo.
Please visit
cloud.google.com/solutions/media
entertainment for more details
and other solutions for media
on Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]